making his 30th start of the season
tonight uh he really has just been
unbelievable over his entire career it's
really hard to fathom as you look at his
era right now is currently first in mlb
as far as the lowest era's concern the
2-1 to tommy pham runners off first and
second
bam it's a ground ball left side seeger
with a backhand a long throw to first on
target
for the padres is ryan weathers and the
21 year old left-hander started uh 17
games this will be his 18th of the
season one out base is empty for corey
seeger he swings the first pitch drives
it a long way to left tommy fam on the
run he won't get it it's off the wall
around first and into second is corey
seeger with his 20th double of the
season 311 hitter with runners in
scoring position
there's a shot through the whole left
side of base hit
seeger's going to get way tall he's
around third throw is cut off by machado
it's one nothing dodgers
trey turner a 15-game hitting streak and
he drives in seeger to get the dodgers
on the board two man out here's max
muncie
this one into the right field of base
head turner's gonna fly around third
he'll score
muncie with a two out rbi single and
it's two nothing dodgers pollock
stepping in at 299 with 17 home run 62
runs batted in
this one's driven to left and deep
going back fan he looks up
a two-run home run hey
dodgers
they want this ball away
see carratini set up look at that for
that fastball down and away that ball
goes over the middle of the plate he
misses his spot and aj paul that puts a
great swing will be facing friend
grisham jerks and profar and victor
caratini
after the next five are over and a line
shot that mookie bets and he makes that
crowd
oh a hot shot right in mook and he hung
with it two ball two strike pitch
and a line shot right at seeger thank
you
two down
aces empty two outs in the top of the
second caratini stands into the
left-handed box go-to pitch who caratini
yeah that was up and he sends it down
the left field line it'll be a home run
that ball is gone victor carratini just
over the short fencing down the left
field line and for carratini his seventh
of the year puts the padres on the board
it's now four to one he goes and gets a
fastball up and away scherzer wanted
that one up and in and it just gets out
front row 330. thank you very much
corey seeger's cranked things up lately
his last six games he's nine for 21.
your bets at first base and one man out
that one ripped fair down the line bits
around second on his way to third seeger
on his way to second monkey being waved
home here comes the throw monkey slides
he is safe
5-1 dodgers
left in his first at-bat 279 27 home
runs 101 runs batted in
machado drives this out to deep right
center field back goes lux at the whoa
it's gone
two-run home run for manny machado his
28th of the year
he goes opposite field off max scherzer
boy not struggling off of max scherzer
anymore and he takes scherzer to right
center field for the two-run shot
swinging and missing that's for sure
tying runners aboard for san diego
in the air to right field pretty deep
bets going back looking up and that ball
is gonna one hop up and over so that'll
score one run they will make myers go
back to third base and the padres are
back within a run it's five to four
gotta wonder if the shouting will cost
scherzer perhaps the psyop
on the ground
to shortstop and it is booted by seeger
and this game is tied
in the back door from third comes myers
and it's five to
here at five stadium the padres and
dodgers are tied at five
strike three
fourth strike out of the night as lament
is gone
there's one away for the padres in the
sixth it's a season high ten hits
allowed for scherzer one on and one out
for will myers
fly ball out to deep center field back
goes lux and he can't catch it
bangs into the wall face first
and coming around is carratini trying to
score
there'll be no throw padres will take a
lead into third base goes myers
and lux is still down
he went full speed into the wall
holding on to his right shoulder gavin
lux looks like he's coming out and dave
roberts coming to get max scherzer so
changes for the dodgers five and a third
tonight a season high 11 hits allowed
six runs five earned
so one out after the triple by will
myers
and the ground ball to first coming home
is muncie smith grabs it they've got
myers hung up
and tanner will tag him out nobody at
second so frazier will take second base
runner at second for jake cronenworth
they're not going to need more as this
ball is sliced to the left and right
there pollock
so bruhl gets a couple quick outs
tommy fam with two on nobody out for the
friars
ground ball down the first baseline to
fairball machado coming around from
second to score
heading to second with an rbi double
goes tommy pham and the padres have a
two run lead on top seven to five
lined into right field a base hit
that'll score hosmer from third
fan behind him gonna try and score throw
goes to second they will and the padres
take a 9-5 lead two men out runners at
second and third for san diego back to
the top of the order and adam frazier
and the air to left center field
drifting over there is cody bellinger
he'll make the catch
and i need a base runner see what pets
can do here luke swings and he hits a
high drive to left mariznick back to the
one and he's got a homerun
bets
home run number 22
and it's nine to six
now max muncie trying to get something
going in the eighth
back swings hits a high drive to right
center field back goes myers he's at the
wall it is gone
maxwell swinging the silver hammer in
the eighth inning
then it's nine to seven
and aj pollock homer in the first
[Applause]
it's
inning
back-to-back home run to the eighth
inning for the dodgers
second one of the night for parliament
one out for bellinger
ballinger handles one to right field
this one's back
[Applause]
up large in the eighth corey sieger a
pair of doubles
this ball is driven to right field going
back it is
[Applause]
absolutely incredible
what an inning
the dodger is a strike away from beating
the padres for the eighth consecutive
time
ken lee's 02 to mariznick
what a win
what a night
11-9 the final score dodgers win their
102nd game of the season
[Music]